[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday june 29th i'm julie chang for
the wall street journal filling in for
zoe thomas
apps that help users monitor their
menstrual cycles and fertility collect
troves of sensitive data and the
question of what happens to that data
has taken on new importance following
the supreme court's ruling last friday
overturning roe vs wade
legal experts say digital breadcrumbs
left by period trackers and fertility
apps could be used against people in
states where abortion is now illegal
so is there a way to protect that data
and what can you do if you've already
been using those apps
here with me to answer those questions
is wsj personal tech columnist nicole
nguyen hi nicole thanks for coming on
the show hi thanks for having me let's
start with some of the different apps
that are out there that help monitor
user periods or fertility how do they
work and how popular are they
these apps that help track your period
and also fertility are very very popular
they're used by millions and millions of
people and not just people with uteruses
who have periods
also partners and parents a lot of these
apps have sharing capabilities that
allow you to share details about your
cycle with your partner or your parents
and
some of the more popular apps that you
may have heard of
include flow clue apple's health app
that's built into the iphone fitbit has
its own period tracker glow natural
cycles
all of these apps are used to help women
figure out when their next period might
be if they have missed a period if
there's something irregular about their
cycle that they can bring up with their
doctor in the future or if they're
trying to get pregnant when they might
be ovulating so these apps contain a
large amount of personal and sensitive
user data how do they get this data and
how accurate is it so this data is
inputted by the user you tell the app
when you're on your period and some apps
also track your temperature your basal
temperature which can help you monitor
when you're ovulating and it's only as
accurate as the data you put in it so
you have to be really diligent about
making sure the first day of your
menstrual cycle is inputted into the app
on the correct day for it to make an
accurate prediction these formulas these
algorithms have long been practiced by
people before phones and apps existed in
paper diaries so they're definitely
tried and true formulas i think one
reason why a lot of people use apps now
is because it's more convenient to input
this data into your app when you're
already checking your email or the
weather than it is to you know maybe
track it in a paper diary
and so once that data is already logged
into an app's system it's not really
easy to pull that data back why is that
generally speaking and this isn't just
true of period tracking apps
once your data is out there in the ether
whether it's in the database of some
company
or anywhere in the cloud it's hard to
know where it's going a lot of companies
say they don't sell data but they can
certainly share data with third parties
and those parties aren't just
advertisers you know they can share it
with analytics companies that help them
determine what kind of mobile devices
their users are using elvis to say that
once your data is out into the ether one
reason why it's hard to pull back is
because it doesn't just live in one
place it often lives in multiple places
and the company that you ask to delete
your data can delete your data off of
its servers
but not necessarily that of its service
partners
so you should always be wary of the type
of service you're sharing your data with
and ideally
the app works locally on your phone and
so it doesn't have to share data to the
cloud at all
and what have these companies been doing
in response to last friday's supreme
court ruling two services we heard from
flow and natural cycles plan to release
an anonymous mode which will decouple
one's data from their personal
information
but they didn't provide details on how
they would do something like that and
really the only way to truly decouple
one from their information is to make
sure that that data is end-to-end
encrypted which means
not even the company can read it and and
so that data can't be shared with anyone
but especially advertisers and
especially law enforcement
have there been instances in the past
where this kind of data was used by
companies or governments in any way
historically in abortion related cases
the digital data that's most interesting
to prosecutors has been search history
and text messages
and so we haven't seen this kind of data
used in cases
but there haven't been that many
abortion related cases because
roe vs wade was just overturned
and so in an era where location data
text messages browsing history search
history are already used for
prosecutions and other kinds of cases we
can imagine
that any kind of data can be used in
those cases at least according to the
legal experts i spoke to
can you walk us through that a bit more
how would you be able to use this period
or fertility data to determine if
someone has or potentially has had an
abortion
so these apps wouldn't be able to tell
you the whole story but they could tell
you
that you may be missed a period and when
you miss that period and also if there
are location tracking abilities where
you were when you missed that period and
thereafter and when you regained your
period
and those are things that can tell you
something about pregnancy or potential
pregnancy
and then
on top of that location data text
messages search history could create
that fuller picture
so for people who are currently using or
want to use these apps what are some
ways they can protect their data what
should they look for ideally you'd look
for an app that's end-to-end encrypted
and so far apple's health app which is
built into the iphone is the only app
that offers that
for other kinds of apps you should look
at their privacy policies to see if they
can or do share and sell your data with
third parties and ideally
the third parties that they are sharing
it with is very limited how they handle
government requests and whether they
notify users if
a law enforcement is requesting their
information and i think generally
speaking you want to stray away from
free apps
because free apps make their money
through advertising and through selling
data to marketers
but that's not always the case some apps
offer a paid subscription like glow
which we looked at
and do share and sell your data so just
pay close attention to that privacy
policy and of course there is always the
option to track your menstrual cycle on
pen and paper which people have been
doing for many many years before apps
existed and there are charts online to
show you how to predict your period and
predict your ovulation
all right that was our personal tech
columnist nicole nguyen nicole thank you
again for being here thanks julie
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing
if you want more tech stories check out
our website wsj.com and if you like our
show please rate and review it you can
do that wherever you get your podcasts
i'm julie chang for the wall street
journal thanks for listening
[Music]
you